bring in a David Pollock from the
mothership part of college game days
crew all day coverage of college
football's national championship game
and kickoff 8:00 Eastern highlights
including a Bill Belichick conversation
where he discusses Nick Saban's success
and their relationship David good
morning how are you
good morning damn great all right what
do you say to people who say no here we
go again Clemson Alabama get better beat
them I mean that's always the thing I
know people get sick of it but this
really is in my lifetime it really feels
like red sox-yankees
you know I mean several years ago the
up-and-coming Red Sox and they hadn't
won in a long time but you had a lot of
talent and then all of a sudden they
break for a breakthrough and then win a
few more and that feels like Clemson and
then the evil empire is Alabama
you know they they're the standard
they've been doing it so it's just tough
man you got you got the greatest coach
of all time people thought Nick Saban
Bear Bryant and what he did would never
be touched and would never be clutched
and Nick Saban and almost half the time
and Alabama has done what Bear Bryant
did and that's that's amazing to think
about and Davos the second best coach in
college football and he's recruited a
higher level and got his guys and it's
cool down to because he does it in such
a different way but he's so different
the way he leads but between Nick and so
it's just you know sit back and relax
and admire greatness and I know you get
sick and tired of in the second two
teams win but it's gonna do something
about it and he'll beat them and don't
let them live okay but it might point to
these people who criticize and say well
I'm not gonna watch in any other sport
what what other sport do you go I get
tired of seeing the two best teams
square off if it's the Super Bowl the
World Series like you want a great story
but in the end March Madness you want to
have the two best teams face off against
each other you know you have that
tonight and just I guess you know maybe
we're we're bored by the greatness of
these two programs especially Alabama
I'm not quite sure and maybe it's you
know regional maybe the fact that you
know you've got Clemson and you've got
Alabama and
rest of the country it's not gonna be
interested I don't know I I'm a little
baffled by it but I would think that you
would want to have the two best teams
and you're gonna have a lot of future
pros playing in the game coming up
tonight so I don't know Oh find it
interesting but not everybody does yeah
you've got a to the top 35 guys ranked
you know I'm Todd mache is bored they'll
play in this game
you know I'm do we always sick of are
you sick of LeBron James and the
Cleveland Cavaliers versus the Golden
State Warriors we've got that one the
last three or four years it's been
freaking amazing I mean it's been I'm
not money you know die hard and be a fam
but I love it because I know the face I
know the team's I know the storylines I
know Kevin Durant joined them you know I
mean I just I saw it I thought it was
fun I think it's been fun to follow and
want so I think people get upset but
here's the thing that you know good and
well people get upset they'll be
watching
they got Alabama to cheer against or a
Clemson that's here against and you know
it'll be it'll be fun to watch and it'll
be it'll be watchable TV yes sure okay
there's a two-part question the best
college quarterback on the field tonight
and the best potential pro quarterback
on the field tonight
ouch I think that's easy because two is
probably better and he had more weapons
and a more complete team more experience
but Trevor Lawrence is filthy and this
dude is I don't know I've never seen a
freshman come in with this much talent
and just he makes 18 yard comebacks
which is like a standard NFL throw that
people look at he makes them look like
it's easy but just his arm talent is
insane and he's gonna be back in this
situation and to is going back in the
situation they're both going to be you
know NFL quarterbacks for a long long
time you know the one difference is
there's not a lot of very successful
left-handed quarterbacks you know if you
think about it the last eighty three
quarterbacks drafted will right-handed
and you know you Steve Young comes to
mind but there's you know Mark Brunell
but there hasn't been a ton of you got
to kind of change your offense when you
have a left-handed quarterback like two
of because your blindside isn't your
left tackle anymore your blindsides your
right tackle
and you know the spin on the ball is
different and so I think both are going
to be successful Trevor Lawrence you
know next level fits in perfect - it
will be a little bit of a different fit
because of he's a little bit more mobile
a little bit shorter and left-handed but
I mean balls are going to be very
successful high draft picks I'm worried
about the voice though David the voice
is weak Godfather when it would happen
huh like did you guys go to dinner and
it was loud you had to yell across the
table or something can you make it
tonight
are you a game time decision David I'm
probable and definitely it's gonna
happen okay it definitely sounds like a
smoke a pack of marbled Reds but no it's
that time of year late in the season and
the West Coast time and figuring it out
but we'll get her down up up here's
something that I was told yesterday that
somebody at Ohio State said that Urban
Meyer's not done coaching and I followed
up by saying okay
where would he be coaching if he's not
gonna coach at Ohio State and he said
Notre Dame or USC well what do you think
I think urban believes he's done you
know and I say that because you know his
health is obviously a concern and he's
warning so you know it's amazing that
he's spent time with Nick saving me some
time with Davo and phenomenal coaches
great great coaches of this generation
Nick the greatest of all time and when
you spend time with urban and the
conversation is so dadgum different and
you know Dabo and nick and these guys
the grinders down and they have tunnel
vision and they're great coaches but
they have the tunnel vision and they're
in the tunnel but they got a flashlight
and they can see where they're going and
they have perspectives like urban urban
doesn't have perspective he's gonna even
a tunnel without a flashlight and it's
just tunnel vision and grind and family
comes net last and everything else comes
last it is the pursuit of greatness so I
understand why he's grinded but the
dudes 54 years old and you know USC
makes a lot of sense Notre Dame makes a
lot of sense because of his ties to
Notre Dame
early in his career so I think he thinks
he's done but at 54 and now he's gonna
go try retirement for a little bit I
don't think he's you know he tried it
once and it took a year sabbatical and
he came right back to Ohio State so I
think we'll see him coach again but I do
think he thinks he's done right now
because of his health yeah I think at 54
and he might be an old 54 but you know
he strikes me as a lifer there they're
just certain guys that they don't and he
could be an analyst but I I would be
shocked if in two years we're not
talking about Urban Meyer coaching again
Kliff Kingsbury has been denied an
opportunity to coach or to interview to
coach in the NFL your thoughts on what
USC is doing with their offensive
coordinator I mean first of all the hire
is phenomenal I mean he is that's a
that's a that's a job saving hire for
help I mean that he is cooking for he's
one of the greatest minds you watch TV
there or you watch the tape of Texas
Tech the last several years and he just
blows your mind and everyone just
catches my home this sure he did it was
you know two or three different
quarterbacks and kept changing the
offense weekly because one of his
quarterbacks would get hurt and it's
just it's amazing it's a brilliant
offensive mind that could make us see so
sexy and he is Hollywood you know that
bed fits perfect his persona his
demeanor his look is everything about
that makes a lot of sense as far as
denying a oh they consider him a
opportunity to interview I mean I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't I wouldn't
go that route I mean I would always let
my guys you know pursue things that they
wanted to pursue things but you know
they also that's a old school USC is an
old school place and lymph lon you know
it's kind of got that Steelers mentality
everybody thought I helped might get
fired and it's like no you know
commitment commitment commitment
commitment so I think they're a brand
that follows the Steelers and that old
regime of you know you listen you have a
job stay committed to it and that's
probably the the realm of thinking
thinking about the ad and Lynn Swann
have fun tonight don't say anything
until you go on the
how about that hey pipe yeah yes yes so
if somebody says something to you make
maybe make a sign if you know write it
down and hand it to somebody right will
do thank you David
that's a David Pollock the ESPN college
football analyst College GameDay crew
kickoff at 8:00 Eastern tonight the
national title game and they got a
feature with Bill Belichick conversation
talking about Nick Saban success and
their relationship for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]